قالت وزاره الصحه في غزه ان قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ارتكبت خلال الساعات الماضيه
16 مجزره بحق العائلات في قطاع غزه راح
ضحيتها
123 شهيدا
و169 جريحا وارتفعت بذلك حصيله العدوان
الاسرائيلي منذ السابع من اكتوبر تشرين
الاول الماضي الى
2778 شهداء واكثر من 67 الف جريح
الان ننتقل الى رفح معنا من هناك مراسل
الجزيره هشام زقوت هشام اخر التطورات في
قطاع غزه هذا الصباح ولنبدا من رفح حيث
انت رفح هي هذه المدينه التي باتت تتعرض
الى القصف الاعنف ربما خلال الايام
الماضيه والساعات القليله الماضيه ايضا
القصف بات على رفح مركزا ويستهدف في جله
منازل مدنيه فلسطينيه نحن نتحدث عن
المدينه الاكثر ضاضا الاكثر كثافه في
السكان ورغم كل ذلك الجيش الاسرائيلي
مستمر في قصفها الجيش الاسرائيلي
والمسؤولين الاسرائيليين مستمرون ايضا في
تهديدها والتهديد لمدينه رفح هو تهديد
خطير لان السكان ونصف سكان قطاع غزه
يتواجدون في رفح الجيش الاسرائيلي بدا
عملياته في رفح او بدا بتكثيف عملياته في
رفح منذ عده ايام وبات يقصف المنازل
المدنيه الفلسطينيه قصف ليله امس منزلين
وكان هناك 14 ع شهيدا خمسه شهداء من بينهم
اطفال وهذا ان دل على شيء فانما يدل على
ان المنازل المدنيه في رفح هي منازل مكتظه
الخيام هي خيام مكتظه جميع المناطق في رفح
هي مكتظه لكن على وجه الخصوص كانت كان حي
تل السلطان والحي السعودي قصف ليله امس
وبالتالي هذين الحيين هما الذين طلب الجيش
الاسرائيلي من سكان قطاع غزه باكمل ان
يتوجهوا الى هذه الاحياء على وجه الخصوص
وبالتالي بعد ذلك يقصفها وهي هي الاحياء
الاكثر ربما اكتظاظا حتى في مدينه رفح
وبالتالي القصف على رفح ربما له خصوصيه في
ظل هذا الاكتضاض السكاني في ظل هذه
الكثافه السكانيه في ظل اوضاع السكان
السيئه والخيام انتشرت على الحدود انتشرت
في الشوارع انتشرت على الارصفه وبالتالي
اي قصف على مدينه رفح هو يوقع عشرات من
الشهداء والجرحى القصف كان على المنازل
القصف كان واستهدف ايضا سيارات الشرطه
التي تؤمن المساعدات من معبر رفح الى
المناطق مختلفه في قطاع غزه ايضا استهدف
كذلك المناطق الزراعيه والمناطق الحدوديه
ما بين جمهوريه مصر العربيه وقطاع غزه
كذلك القصف المدفعي مستمر في كل لحظه على
المناطق الشرقيه لمدينه رفح القصف ايضا
مستمر على المناطق التي تفصل ما بين مدينه
خانيونس ومدينه رفح منطقه قيزان النجار
وقز رشوان هذه المناطق تتعرض الى قصف عنيف
من الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه القصف
ربما الاكثر عنفا هو في خانيونس مازالت
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه تنفذ ما بين
فينه واخرى غارات على مدينه خانيونس
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه ايضا تقصف مناطق
مختلفه في مدينه خانيونس لكنها تركز قصفها
على محيط مستشفى ناصر وايضا ما زال محيط
مستشفى الامل يتعرض الى قصف عنيف من
الطائرات وكذلك من المدفعيه الاسرائيليه
القناصه ينتشرون في مدينه خانيونس وما بين
فينه واخرى يطلقون النار حتى على
المواطنين الذين يحاولون الحصول على شربه
ماء بال بالقرب من بالقرب من مستشفى ناصر
وعلى شارع البحر وهو الشارع الاساسي
والرئيسي لمدينه خانيونس وبالتالي القصف
على خانيونس بات مكثفا هناك عدد من
الشهداء ما زالوا في الشوارع ولم تستطع
سيارات الاسعاف والطواقم الطبيه انتشالهم
ما زال القصف ايضا على مناطق مختلفه في
خانيونس واطلاق النار حتى من طائرات
استطلاع كواد كابتر اسرائيليه ايضا القصف
مستمر على المنطقه الوسطى منطقه شرق منطقه
المغازي تتعرض ما بين فينه واخرى الى قصف
من المدفعيه الاس اسرائيليه وهناك حديث عن
شهداء وعمليه انتشال لشهداء من تلك
المنطقه الحديث عن خمسه شهداء من شرق مخيم
المغازي يتم انتشالهم جراء قصف اسرائيلي
مدفعي على تلك المناطق ايضا في مدينه غزه
ما زالت ما زالت عمليه القصف في المنطقه
الغربيه الرمال الجنوبي ومنطقه مخيم
الشاطئ ومنطقه الميناء مازالت تتعرض الى
قصف عنيف من المدفعيه وكذلك من الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه وعمليه الاطلاق النار
ايضا مستمره في تلك المناطق شكرا لك هشام
قوت مراسل الجزيره كنت معنا من رفح جنوب
قطاع غزه